thank you so much for having us uh join
your podcast
and we are sitting in thai's hut this is
the hut that he lives and he wrote books
and he
did a lot of his work so
i would love to just give you a glimpse
of his
sitting still hut if you're up for it
yes we'd love to see tiknot hans hot
that's fantastic
okay we're gonna give you an exclusive
tour of
so this is
when when the attendance we come in this
is the kitchen
uh this is where we do our podcast
recording of the way out is in
uh this is where tai makes his breakfast
he would always make scrambled tofu
instead of scrambled egg
and
now we will enter into his living space
so
here you have his
simple bed i'm gonna turn on the light
give me one second
so
this is his bookshelf it's very classic
is some bricks and just
pieces of logs
this is how this is how he keeps it and
we're not allowed to change his style
this is where
he sleeps
these is the coats and ropes that he
would wear
and this is the table where he wrote
many of his books
and translated many of the sutras
from classical chinese or pali sanskrit
into vietnamese english and french
and this is his famous corner where he
would host all of his guests
and where he had his tea
and this is his tv his television it's
late at night but
it's a very beautiful landscape he's
we're on a hill here so you see the
whole field of sunflowers vineyards etc
and he would invite people to watch his
television with him whenever they have
tea
and especially right now this is this
altar
but you see two urns and these are ashes
our teachers ashes
that are here
wow
so
so every monastery in the plum village
tradition receives an urn with a portion
of his ash and when
depending on each community we'll do a
ceremony to spread our teachers ashes
yeah
and uh
this is him at i believe 17 years old
uh wow yeah 17 years old a young monk
and uh yeah this is his rocking chair
though we would always uh
tell stories and he has
every every every hut he would have a
hammock
that he would um string across the hut
for him to chillax
[Laughter]
yeah so this is his hot it's very simple
and it's
the way he likes he likes it to be
so you get an
exclusive
inner look
so
metaphysical milkshake youtube viewers
um you've got an exclusive bonus
episode a tour of tiknot hans living
quarters that's so beautiful thank you
so much for sharing that with us that's
very meaningful in
how simply and modestly he lived
for a religious leader who was revered
by
tens or hundreds of millions and um
[Music]
i'm sure he could have profited so much
but to live so modestly and humbly and
beautifully that's really gorgeous to to
witness thank you
thank you to both of you
well enjoy the rest of your day
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you